I like that hat you're wearing you know
what it is no no your eyes aren't
playing tricks on you that's Jennifer
Lopez video chatting with her fiance
Alex Rodriguez and her ex Diddy awkward
a key you have to know this you have to
know this is I don't think know that
this guy right here is your biggest fan
from the bad boy air are you amazed like
are his heroes okay it's like every
party we do anything okay so actually it
turns out it's not awkward like at all
I appreciate the love they write you
know came oh man
that's right in fact JLo and Diddy might
be the friendliest exes on the planet
here's what went down on Sunday did he
kicked off what he called the world's
biggest dance Lathon on instagram live
in an effort to raise money for health
care workers in underserved areas amid
the corona virus outbreak my rock would
you do something I don't want to date a
that it's so on me you check it out
which one yeah you got it you guys get
ready
you good you like the bird you like Jen
was just one of the stars to join in on
the party and it was cute from the jump
[Music]
sweet right well it got way cuter when J
Lo's fiancee joined the convo here's my
brother yeah so it turns out a rod big
fan of Diddy I mean just look at him
shake it to one of Diddy songs I said
he's the dancing to me I mean I would
leave the dancing to JLo to just look at
her anyway
it wasn't all dancing and a letting
loose company work right and we come
from the bottom and these people they
are the real heroes sometimes we have
they're the heroes in the front line
protecting us protecting the wounded
God's work Willie yeah they had a pretty
heartfelt convo about why it was
important to give back just don't
thankful and appreciative and that's
like you know P and what we're trying to
do with everything it's really just use
our platform to be able to honor them
because is our debt to them we owe it is
not something that we should be
celebrated for this is our duty because
God has put us in a position to be able
to help and give back and that's what
we're doing just a small part is it's
the least we can do so we're very
thankful yes yes we got to Liddy's
livestream dance party also featured
appearances from Justin Bieber will
smith la la
Anthony Kevin Hart Drake Mark Wahlberg
Issa Rae and tons of others like Liz Oh
[Music]
yeah things got a little awkward when
lizzo started to twerk while Diddy sons
danced on his account I'm sorry I'm
sorry I'm sorry fun no my limos and
while Diddy shut down Liz omid twerk he
didn't seem to have a problem when model
Draya Michele showed off her moves a few
hours later we killed that I think I
think that was one of the top
performances of the night
well fans weren't too happy about that
and hit up social media to let Diddy
know Liz oh we love you and everybody
you know everybody stopped looking for
the negative look at the positive man
let's go to the love later the rapper
explained on his in story hey yo there's
one thing that I want to make clear like
my queen my sister Liz oh when I stopped
the music it was cuz it had a lot of
curses in there not cuz she was twerking
she's one of the best workers in the
world okay so let's keep that clear Liz
Oh reposted all that to her insta story
too so it's all good guys and according
to Diddy the fundraiser brought in over
three million dollars in the first few
hours should we do them beats up again
may God bless job you know I just love
you guys
[Music]